hoy se celebra en estambul el primer
concierto de una serie de conciertos del
famoso rapero ruso oxímoron que se ha
exiliado de su país para hacer una serie
de conciertos en contra de la guerra en
ucrania en contra de la invasión del
presidente ruso vladimir putin hace algo
más de dos semanas de hecho este rapero
canceló varios conciertos en su país que
tenían vendidos completamente para irse
del país y hablar en contra de esta
guerra que y el simple hecho de hacerlo
en rusia ya es considerado como un
crimen y puede mantener al mandarle a
uno varios años a la cárcel el concierto
de hoy para concepto de ver una cola muy
larga que ya ha sido en por cierto ha
sido completamente ex abrió las entradas
han terminado y no nos dejan entrar pero
la mayoría de la gente que está viniendo
a este concierto son rusos que salieron
hace poco del país precisamente por
miedo a tener represalias y a ser
encarcelados por haber por hablar en
contra de esta guerra son muchos
periodistas activistas también
opositores que han salido del país y
cuyo ex cuyo destino mayormente ha sido
está muy el único puerto grande puerto
gran puerto europeo que tiene aún vuelos
directos con moscú y con rusia también
muchos han ido a yereván en armenia
tbilisi georgia pero la mayor puerta de
entrada y de salida de hecho de rusia ha
sido la turquía y estambul en particular
a muchos rusos aquí nos cuentan que han
huido de su país por este miedo que
tienen a las represalias que podrían
recibir por hablar en contra de la
guerra y hoy mismo se celebra un acto
para precisamente celebrar este estar en
contra de un conflicto que muchos rusos
aunque no puedan decirlo abiertamente no
quieren